[Applause]
[Music]
all right day two and now we're gonna
learn how to hunt truffles so excit I
honestly never liked truffles back home
in the States
I tried truffle and it tastes like
battery acid to me it was like but being
here and trying these truffles I'm like
oh so this is what truffles supposed to
taste like
okay now on the fan yes is there a place
that isn't gorgeous urination I haven't
seen anything that's ugly here like even
the gas stations are not so beautiful
here so first for their stars I would
like to offer you return home a trendies
it's early but it's never too early for
a good friend we say here nice um here
so both I for Brandy's are typical for
this region and especially for city of
to set were you today people a
breakfast for breakfast brandy breakfast
for champions - oh wow this is strong -
sweet - sweet so you train problems
family one more time welcome
frozen is the family name is the surname
and the dopamine truffles in Croatian
[Music]
like a baseball-sized truffle this is
the biggest ever
[Music]
it smells totally differently I want to
taste like that's true actually smells
like a berry yeah it smells so good
yes smells like a berry right yeah and
then look at the duck hunters oh my god
what a cutie they know you're holding
the truffle they know your hood so
what'd you learn about our truffle
hunting that it's a very difficult
process and that every time you go
hunting you're not always gonna receive
gifts from nature that sometimes it'll
take a long time for you to just take
anything and then that there's different
types of truffles like in every season
there's a different type of black
truffle and then that white truffle
those are like 10 times more expensive
and that white truffles are only grown
in two places in the world which is here
in the Central District and in Italy
which is really interesting because I
didn't know that and yeah and so like
pretty much you train these doggies to
go with the issues saying that all these
families are on here in istria that they
usually have more dogs than they do have
family members cuz they each family has
like 5 dogs and that they train these
dogs to help them hunt for the truffles
and the way that the truffles are born
in the wild is after animals like wild
animals like wild boars they'll eat them
and then put them out near some trees
and then after
animals poop amount and the spores will
attach to the trees and then like in
about eight months you'll get truffles
that's super interesting and then she
also said that well you can cultivate
black truffles but it will take about
eight to nine years for you to see any
truffle sprout from the baby young trees
and so she has some trees planted that
they planted about eight years ago and
then finally now they said she found one
like tiny little truffle it took 8 years
that's crazy
so that's why they're so expensive so
now we're gonna eat breakfast and then
we're gonna go hunt some truffles
undecided XL hungry I already had brandy
for breakfast I know you know what I
really like about a stria is that the
people here really live that good life
you know they do and I love how they
love their life in like the culture that
they're in and like their heritage are
so beautiful you could see all the love
and the passion that they put into
everything that's around here bread the
first one I left the white one it's mix
of flex truffle pesto in the cream
cheese the next one it's called white a
2-parter it's a pathetic mix of white
truffles a little bit of black truffles
and cream and cheese and then the third
one is mix of white truffles and porcini
mushrooms
we can't we continue in the good streak
of truffle experiences right now oh yeah
continuing the I'm not worthy strict to
the good life and check out the view
that we have right now I could get used
to this yeah
[Music]
now we had the truffles so good who's
making truffle scrambled in front of our
car this is something which is a dish
which is very traditional simple easy to
make and very delicious just with a few
ingredients now we add some cheese on
top
it's a truffle cheese it can be any kind
of cheese in it now we add some more
truffles on top is a special slicer it's
adjustable knife you can make thinner or
thicker slices and then shave on top
it's a powerful piece you can imagine if
you have to have a turn of Beast
people when they come here they're like
what one shilling will be 20 euros
and then he has some truffle salad also
we shave some truffles now extra truffle
with some I decide right now
well this is fun
the thing is they're very expensive
activity right here that's good yes
they're so creamy and fluffy and
truthfully it's so amazing I honestly
have never left trouble as much as I
have today well you're in the heartland
of right now with bunny with white rice
yeah we make the honey and gelato is
made here in one local family they have
their own gelatin yeah oh my gosh I was
trying to put the flavors together in my
head like honey truffle oh that's it
such a good time and with a very strange
brain
people are like what - truffles and
something sweet but isn't completely
going good
[Music]
the good life all right we're going
truffle hunting they're going Wow really
it's out here you see the pieces you see
here he's eating it okay you always have
to pay attention to what they do because
they can find one and then we when you
were being this tough law they can go in
and other parts and find another one eat
it
[Music]
[Music]
with that gold nice one out of the
ground I smells like there's more nobody
can be some more it can be some more you
always have to give them travel treats
because in that way you keep them eager
you know to search 50ml goo stick
[Music]
Wow nice one and we're walking on like
lots of money here because those are all
together it can't be like this for very
long time that much in the short period
is so fluffy so many good things in a
sharpie yeah
yeah playing you know it's like it works
done
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
she's dead for the last two weeks she
hasn't found as many troubles as she did
with us today so we're lucky all right
so now we're gonna be visiting the
smallest town in the world called boom
it's right behind me and apparently
there's only a population of 21 people
it's super super tiny and you guys know
how much I love Tammy thinks I'm so
excited to see this town 21 people it's
like one family that's less than our
wedding party the question is can you
get lost in the city this looks like one
of those towns or cities or whatever
lodges forts that were built in like the
medieval era came here it has a
population of 21 as per the 2011
consensus but apparently there's been
more kids born in the last few years
twenty eight in total is twenty eight
was first mentioned and documents dating
from 1102 I love coming to places I have
so much history I'm so cool I wish I
could like trace back my lineage like
that probably cuz what you're scared you
to work you know it's really weird being
out here in Istria is the fact that my
allergies don't act up like I've haven't
had to take any allergy medicine and
back home it's like the moment I'm in
like wild nature's type stuff my sinuses
and like eyes go crazy
but for some reason out here it's like
good nature like I'm not having
any sort of congestion or anything like
that so whatever they have in the water
and the air out here is good for me
maybe I should retire here should we
retire here come down okay that's the
plan now guys we're do retiring out in
Istria one of these days from or sixty
years old yeah one of these days and
we're sick baby
it's like a mini picnic we're gonna have
a little picnic right before we go into
the town of hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
music I know what an entrance
[Music]
this is like a fairy tale like like
Robin Hood lived here and stuff yeah so
where's the first place you want to go
to in this town imagine growing up in
this town and then going to Lane New
York City yeah the little kids re always
uses strangers walking little
this is amazing backyard right the view
this kinda reminds me of a look up oh
yeah mm-hmm
oh we stayed in and then there was kids
throwing up with the view similar to
this we're gonna brandy shop in there oh
this is delicious really good in taste
like time a little bit guy cough syrup
yeah I could see what you're saying with
this would you like something yes maybe
and a lion marmalade what small wasting
like a dandelion what are the deadlines
moment I don't know
oh just his exam
[Music]
is it like apple juice dandelions can
overflow just standing your life yeah I
can't quite pinpoint it tastes good
[Music]
welcome to talk Larry
[Music]
all isn't strong oh you know good read
the nashville's I don't like just that
much but I always try to find something
to like about it it's sweet it's made
from rose it's a little bit Samara roses
yeah but it's sweet like roses but it
also kind of prick sore throat and no
nostrils like a rose Rose thorns
[Music]
drinking baby for sure tomorrow my face
is gonna be fat he's not like a girl
drinking makes me look fat I didn't
finish my did me one swing is pretty
awesome drinking this stuff though or at
least for me
tasting it in like in a 600 year old
olive oil mill that has been transformed
into a restaurant oh yeah
ultra the more serious things where are
we I just said it
[Music]
you know parachute loss what I'm gonna
say okay you're drunk that's okay maybe
now I'm just getting sensitive too much
too much drinking oh it smells good the
entire bread is so good I'm so sleepy
kay this is so relaxing if this was a
yelp review this is like through the
roof like ten huh atmosphere quality of
food service the water
[Music]
[Music]
in comes a chocolate cake oh but you
were just asking are we gonna have
dinner in three hours cuz you never know
it I'm gonna be feeling in through how
do you feel about olive oil and sweets
it's an interesting mix but olive oil
especially the one that they use here
it's so it's so light and I don't know
what's the worrying rescaling in so much
it looks intense
I thought you would finish your answer
by now I don't know the olive oil is
really light to the point where it
doesn't overpower it
and plus oil is used in baking we
shouldn't be that
[Music]
so beautiful here they're saying that
this is the most beautiful town and not
just history uh but all operations
I gotta update my story
[Music]
[Music]